Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at Candy's 3
Now, we may have a new opponent
in the next night
but we still have to explore more here
Hello! Hi dresser, how you doin'
Hey Cat!
"I have bad news! I think the cat is lurking around tonight. (but your the Cat?)
You have to be extra careful now.
The Monster Cat is very sneaky, you see.
He'll probably try to get you from behind.
Check around each end of your bed as often as you can.
He could appear from either the very left or the very right side.
The flashlight thing will work on him too
so remember to be extra sharp tonight!"
Well that sounds bad on all accounts; I don't know why I'd do that?
"My toy box, where I put all my toys."
Good! I'm glad you're organized.
"My old dresser." Where I put all my dresses
Very organized.
Alright, so what I gotta do is I gotta go into the Dreamscape
Uhh threee?
"When the shadow cat is here, your time in the darkness will be short.
Do not waste your time for when it runs out he'll find you."
I juu dunno wha that means
There's nothing on the back I don't know what that means...
Well that's a slow tick, I think I am good
"The only path is not always the right path."
East from this rock
Alright, I tru- Ohh
Hey
Alrighty then
Wooh
Fucking, I didn't expect you to be there, douche-nazzel!
I thought I was just gonna deal with the cat!
I thought that was gonna be a new thing that happen to me!
Well screw you then. I'm not gonna go that way first.
I'm gonna go this way and then...
Well shit...
Oh OK alright we're good I guess
I don't know
Hello!
"Part of a newspaper article. Read it?"
Sure!
"The Rat and Cat Theater. The perfect place of entertainment for children of all ages!
"We have a show every one of the 5 weekdays!"
Well great, what does that mean for me?
I'm in a dream!
Why do I remember newspaper ads in a dream?
What kind of...
Commercal- AH!
Fffff
Fuck!
Alright, fine then. You wanna play that game, huh?
I can play that game with you.
So I gotta explore here, I'll be right back!
No!
AHH- I saw it! I saw it with my eyeballs!
OK, so I gotta go North.
Schwibidy dupty
I'm crossing the barrier. No one can stop me!
Please don't stop me.
Don't stop me. Don't s- AHH FUCKING FUCK YOU!
I was almost there...
WOOAHOOOHOAAHAAA- I did it!
WOAH
"The monsters will knock on the doors when they become angry,"
"but they only knock on one of the doors that they're not at."
"Monsters always try to fool you."
Do they now.
"There's nothing on the back."
Well that's an interesting note...
Hello
Part of a newspaper. Suure...
"Enjoy the show, enjoy the company!"
"We even have 3 arcade machines you can enjoy while you wait!"
Alrighty then...
This seems decrepit.
Why am I here?
Where am I going?
I don't know where I've come from or where I've been...
OH- OK. I know that's... yeah
That's the eastern way to the...
The frickdickin... whatchemacallit?
Yeah the rock
The Dwayne of the Rocka Joohhnson
Alright
HA- This way!
Yep! I got it! Okay
Part of a newspaper. Let's read!
"Everyone will have fun, even the adults!"
"We have an area for adults to chat while enjoying free coffee!"
What does that mean?
HII- NO, no No no NO!
I've been escaping from you, yeah!
You think you're so evil now?
Well, look how evil I am as a little girl all alone...
*pvvvvvvvv-dodododoo*
Ah, hello
HEY- Found arcade game three- WHA?
Part one?
Part one?!
Shwu!
AHHHHHHH
AH- OK, I don't know...
Maybe I can make, like, the time run out or something...
You don't know which way I'll come from, do ya?
Ohh- Miss me!
Well, I just got back on the normal route I guess...
You don't know which way I'm coming from
Where did I come from? Where did I go?
Where did I come from Cotton Eye Joe?
*random noises mixed with singing*
Duck!
"Oh, It's you!"
"I don't mind if you don't remember me."
"We used to play when you were very very little"
"I was one of your first toys!"
"but that was maaany years ago."
"I probably don't matter anymore."
"You should move along with your life"
"If you have anything to say, say it now."
Ah, I mean: Hello! I guess...
I don't know what to say exactly
I dunno
But I've got a technique to avoid the rat!
A little bit, at least throw him off my trail.
Ahey-less he does that!
Unless he does THAT
Shubudewhoopdy schubedooo
*starts singing in gibberish*
Okay
*Resumes singing in gibberish* Ah!
Fuck you
So where is the other goddamn thing then?
Hoo ha
Can't touch me
The only other thing to do that I can think of
would be to let the time run out
I dunno what that's gonna mean, but
might as well give it a go, so see you in a few minutes.
Alright, here we go
Whatever this is gonna do
ten, nine
eight, seven
six, five
four
Threeeee?
Twooooo?
ONE?
*DOOM* Uahhh
That's it? Alright, okay.
Alright so I can't seem to find anything
else, and I don't want to spend
forever just wondering in the darkness
So, I've got one-half of the arcade game
and I found a toy
I don't know what else to do.
Go to sleep?
Yeah.
*Thunder rumbles in game* Man.
If I really need to, I guess I could go back,
but without a map, I'm gonna be...
Kinda lost, so
Just gotta do what I can against the MONSTER CAT now
who likes to lurk at the foots of my bed
So where you be, kitty-kat?
where you be? Huh
So I gotta look at the extreme left
Ahuh!
I heard-heyhey I heard that
I forgot about my music!
I can't sleep without my mus--
HEY!
Hey! Okay, alright, that was really creepy
Why you be doing that
Gonna be hard for me to tell my nightmare stories
if you're lurking at the foot of my bed
Maybe you're under my bed, too
Eesh
Uh!
I saw that!
Saw that!
Yeeeh
Aw, man, see, it's really creepy because if you
just glance over 'em, it doesn't count
Ya gotta actually... spot 'em
'n see these eyes staring at ya
from the darkness
oh boy
ah frick, where'd you go?
I see you in there
Uheeeeey I HEARD THAT, TOO!
You made a noisey-nu
Uh boy
Okay, so
You guys apparently want more nightmare stories
Dunno why
I got a lot of 'em
So
Woo
Heard that
Oh boy
Hi
Okay, alright.
Anyway, SO
*gibberish*
Why do I have to deal with TWO OF 'EM
Mm
So
A lot of my nightmares mostly
happened when I was a kid
Uh
There were very, um...
UuuuuuuUUUUUUAAAAAH
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS
WHAT WAS THAT
What was with the 'THWOOM'?
*shivers*
Anyway
A lot of my nightmares, um..
that happened when the-
the dream *starts* out normal and fun
And-and free, but, um..
*THWOOM* Oh, shit
As a kid-- I don't know why I'm super nervous this time--
--but as a kid, I would have
A lot a' lucid dreams, like *a lot* of lucid dreams
I used to be able to lucid dream
prrreettty much whenever I wanted to!
*knock*
It was freaking--
euh
No, you're not gonna knock there
Ah! I've gotcha!
The knocks are a lie!
*groan*
So, I would be able to lucid dream
I haven't been able to have a lucid dream in a long time
until... just recently, like, a few months ago
But, when I was a kid
I was able to
Just... fly around and
*knock*
Oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy--
*a wild ratata appeared!*
HEY!
Fuck! I didn't expect you to be in the middle!
Shoop! Shoop! Shoop!
Okay, this is going to end up with you under my bed, isn't it?
Shiiiiiiiit...
God, how much light do you need?
Fucking Vitamin D-deficient BIIITCH
Where ya at?
*inaudible*
*Silence, recorder plays in background*
Aaaaaaah! Aaah!
Is your friend here?
Your friend, the cat, there?
There he is, he is there
Can Iook at him, please?
Oh god oh god oh god, where'd he go?
Oooo, don't scare me
Don't you sneak on me!
By the immortal words of my mom in the face of anything:
"Fredilicious...
...don't sneak on me"
God dammit, I really can't
fucking focus on anything!
Okay! So!
LUCID DREAM!
ME! KID! NIGHTMARES! DREAMS!
....it happened a lot
So.
Uh, it usually started out very fine, um...
Where I was able to control, but as time went on,...
I would just, like... the nightmares would devolve.
Or the dreams would devolve into nightmares.
*thwoom* Eh, fuck
And I just wouldn't be able to control them anymore
Like, it was the weirdest sensation
To have a lucid dream and then slowly have control ripped from my hands
Like, I was in a world where I was able to fly and do whatever I wanted.
It was raining in the front yard *thwoom* and sunshine in the backyard, you know, that sort of thing--
And I think, like, as a kid, you're able to do that just because your world is much smaller,
Therefore your dreams don't have as much, you know, stuff to work with.
So it's easier to, when you know your world very well, especially
If you just, like, grew up in the same house or, you know, you don't go to school yet, or something like that
Or you go to,like, a very small school, which I did when I was growing up, it's easier to *know* you're dreaming
Because you'll be able to tell the differences.
BUT! This didn't happen whenever these lucid dreams started turning into nightmares because...
I would just be in my backyard
And I would be playing around with my brother or something
Or uh... In the dream, of course, I'd be playing around with my brother
And then, like, I was able to control it,
And you know, for some reason  I didn't recognize that my brother wasn't also dreaming with me
You know, he obviously was in there, but in the dream I thought he was.
And then, I would turn around and he'd be gone.
Hey! Okay, hello.
Hi-dee-hi-dee-ho!
How you doin'?
(*mark is in the zone*)
Uuuuhh, god dammit
Get under there
Okay. Alright. We can deal with this.
Why does the music always stop when you pop out?
Frick-a-dick, frick youuu
'Kay, at least I took care of the cat first
So that's an important lesson to learn:
If the cat's there, you gotta take care of the cat first.
Yeah, that's good. That's real good.
Okay.
So, my brother would just be gone
And then I would be in the backyard alone, and then suddenly, like, I knew I was dreaming
But I couldn't control it anymore.
Like, tried to fly. Couldn't do it.
Oooo, frick a dick
So, it-it-it didn't end like anywhere cataclysmic,
It's not like vines started growing out of the ground or anything like that.
It was just like I just had this overwhelming sense of dread when I was in there.
Because, like, my brother was *gone*
and, like, the sky got a little bit darker, and then everything just started getting a little darker
And so, I went the only place I thought he could be, and I went into the woods.
Like, because we had this creek by our house that we'd always go and play together in,
Just me and my brother
And it was just always good to go back there.
So I just assumed he went back there,
but, then, when I stepped, like, *into* the boundary into the forest,
Like, I started to forget that I was lucid dreaming.
Like, I forgot. It was the weirdest thing when I woke up and realized it,
But I forgot that I was in control.
And then control was completely ripped from me
And I was just wondering, endlessly in the creek,
Like over and over again, endlessly,
everywhere I went, looking for my brother, calling out for him, crying.
Like, I was just completely distraught that my brother was gone
Because it-it was like this transition
of mind, when you believe the dream is a dream
And then suddenly the dream is *real*, and it was just
ah, it was terrifying, I woke up from that and I had to go, like,
Check on my brother to make sure he was still there,
Not outside,
Lost in the woods.
God.
But there are, like, tons of occurrences like that,
Where, um, but that was just the earliest example I that could think of,
Where I was able to lucid dream as a kid, and then control is just gone.
And so, like, uh, it was only, like until about a year later
That my lucid dreams just stopped in general.
I wasn't able to
Aaaah
I heard that, yeah
Think you can trick me?
You can not!
You can not
ya can not
Yeah
So I haven't been able to lucid dream for a long time
just like
I can only remember once or twice
In my teenage years and then
once just recently
IS THAT A KNOCK is that IS ACTUALLY A THING or IS it
just a FAKEY thing
YEEEEEEEEE
Think I'm gonna win though
Which is good
Like I don't know how many years
GUYS
OUT THERE
Can lucid dream
awwwww shit
DON'T SCREW THIS UP FOR ME
BECAUSE I...
eh
Damn it
OH NO DON'T DO THAT TO ME
NOOOOOOOOOO
DON'T YOU FUCKING DARE
I
CAUGHT YA
HAHA I GUESSED IT
Da-fuck is going on with my player
STOP THAT
STOP
Okay
so they interrupted it or something
or it got caught up
and nothing
I dont like that
alright
Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you
yaaaaa that's right
HIYAYE GO AWAY
ok
everything quiet
(RING) YAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
OK
alright
Geez that was stressful
I don't know why
huh
having that cat in the room doesn't make me any happier
what is this
Are we going back?
ell up
We're back alright
Now what do you've got for me
What sort of other horrible monstrosities
Are awaiting for me here
oh hey you again!
my daddy said that the puppeteer's puppet is a double-puppet
It means it's both a string-puppet,
And a ventilowist-puppet
Do you know not how to say ventrilo-
oh hey
Hello there kid!
I'm the Puppeteer
Normally, my friend Viennie is with me,
But he's resting right now
Maybe you'll get to meet him after today's show,
If you want to!
mmm... I don't know
I don't know if I want to
Seems like a bad idea all around
eugh
Just everything about this nightmare world
Hi sweetie, have you met the puppeteer?
He's here early today
Okay
If you say so
Dad, I don't know why you keep bringing me here
When they only cause me nightmares
I met the Puppeteer! He's my friend now!
I've even made a drawing for him. He really liked it!
Now I've drawn a drawing for the Cat and the Puppeteer!
Now I just need the Rat as my friend too!
Ok, that's how friendship works
I already beat my old highscore on all the games...
Not like I could ever use those skills for anything useful
I wonder if you could get paid for playing games in the future?
huh
This kid seems to have a grasp on things in life
BUT NO ABSOLUTELY NOT
oh no
HEY! It's my little pal! Early for the show as usual!
Up for another round of hide-and-seek?
What happens if I say no?
Don't be sad because I won last time...
Tell me if you change your mind. a'right?
Up for another round?
How bout yes?
Neato! You hide again, then I'll count
alrighty then
goody goody gumdrops
I doubt your gonna tell me
Nah, you're not gonna tell me anything new are ya?
No, the answer is no
Can I hide in the girl's room?
What about the table right under my dad?
DAD PROTECT ME
THERE'S A CRAZY RAT
BOO
Ok gotchu
gotcha again
I don't know if there's any way to win that
I doubt it anyway
alright
Whelp
Anyway
Guess that's it for that night
Eh that was too easy
I did even lose on that night
So I gonna continue onto the fourth
And see if I can dive deeper into the mystery here